it's great to welcome back to the
program today Alok kenosha who is a
psychiatrist practicing in Boston and on
the faculty at Harvard Medical School
also the co-founder of healthy gamer an
organization that uses meditation and
the latest in neuroscience and
psychotherapy advances to help video
gamers take back control of their lives
all oh great to have you on thanks a lot
David
so we have heard this week in the wake
of a couple of mass shootings once again
this idea of we should be looking at
violence in video games as a possible
cause of the the real-world violence
that was committed by these young
individuals so there's a few different
things that I've been talking about one
is do we even know anything about the
gaming history of these individuals if
we don't then what are we even really
talking about number two even if we did
that would not necessarily be a causal
relationship and there's quite a bit of
scholarship actually about the link
between violence in video games and
other forms of media and real world
violence and then beyond that when we
look particularly at El Paso you had
really what word to me white nationalist
anti-immigrant motivations which I don't
know for sure but that I've not seen
that as a theme of any video games I've
heard of nevertheless so where can we
what's a good entry point for us if we
want to think about this from a
scientific and medical perspective to
even start considering whether this is a
possibility absolutely so that's a
fantastic question I think the best
entry point is there was a study that
was actually published this year which
is something called a meta-analysis
which pulls data from lots of different
studies and sees if we can draw an
overarching conclusion and there was a
study that was done this year that
basically showed that there if there is
an effect which it's not really clear
whether there is or isn't the effect is
incredibly small and specifically what
video games do is in in a very small way
increase internal feelings of aggression
right but the interesting thing about
the study is that the reason that the
effect size is so small is because there
have been many many
he's done over the last decade that have
really conflicting results so one study
done in 2015 basically which is a very
rigorous study found that there is no
effect of increasing violent tendencies
or even feelings of aggression
after playing video games there are some
fMRI studies which are sort of
functional neuroscience imaging studies
which show that playing video games
actually suppress our emotional the
emotional parts of our brain and this is
why like you know if you've had a long
day and you're stressed out and you go
home and you play a video game like that
helps you feel better because it
actually shuts off emotional parts of
your brain and so let me dig into that a
little because there's already a lot
there that I think is relevant talked
about so you you talked about the
possibility of being linked to
aggression in some general sense in some
studies when I interviewed Erika Shar
from the University of Massachusetts six
years ago whose perspective is more from
a communication sociology perspective
she at the time was involved in a lot of
similar scholarship which suggested at a
very broad level that there are some
studies which show that video games can
sort of set off or encourage aggressive
behavior in people with certain
predispositions already but that
anything beyond that it does not seem to
be supported by the scholarship it
sounds like you're not saying the same
thing but you're sort of thinking along
the same lines in your interpretation
well yeah so I think the big difference
is that over the last six years we've
had way more studies right and and the
simple fact is that they're highly
conflicting which generally speaking
suggests that you know so you have some
studies that show that there's no link
you have some studies that show that
there are increasing feelings of
aggression but feelings of aggression
also don't correlate to real-world
violence so there's a big gap in even if
you say that a videogame increases
feelings of aggression which is easily
disputed the effect is relatively small
and then it's a big jump to say feelings
of aggression increase or correlate to
real-world violence like so if you could
look at even something like sporting
events like people have high feelings of
aggression
sporting events but we don't blame like
football for mass shootings and so that
causative link is still like it's it's a
huge positive way yeah although I wonder
if we could blame some of those
escalated feelings of aggression during
sporting events for fights during and
after the sporting events themselves
which is quite a common phenomenon
absolutely right but but in that case
you have a curl you have a temporal link
because you have sports fans that are
inebriated and and really gung-ho about
their their team and then they get into
fights yeah
but that's that's a far cry from for
video games let me prepare something
else not as something I think is the
case but that I I think should be
considered if we're opening up the store
which is is it possible that playing a
violent video game could actually be a
substitute for committing real-world
violence and I'm asking this not in a
rhetorical sense like is that a
possibility yes absolutely so I think
that there's actually neuroscience data
to suggest that that is the case so when
someone feels aggressive like I was
saying earlier like when you feel like
aggressive or pissed off about something
playing a video game like why are they
fine why are they recreational it's
because they sort of they they decrease
our negative experience of emotion in
the moment which is exactly what
recreation is designed to do so I've
worked with a lot of gamers and have
actually found the so I started out sort
of working with people around helping
them with video game addiction but the
more I've worked with gamers over the
last year I've started to appreciate
more and more positive effects of video
games and I think that that's an area of
research which is like completely
untouched because everyone's focusing on
an addiction now people are focusing on
violence but there are a lot of
potential positive effects of video
games which we we're just sort of
scratching the surface for yeah I mean
it feels weird to me to be coming out
and and really trying to expose the the
sort of lack of substance between behind
starting to blame video games as a sort
of concerted talking point for these
shootings and the reason it feels weird
is because as a you know student of
communication there are so many err
in which we should be talking about the
effect on culture society psychology of
the messages that we get from media this
includes news media this includes movies
and TV shows and it includes video games
and and social media whether it comes to
anti-social behavior whether it could
there you know there's so much material
here of things we really should be
talking about that it feels strange to
now have to be put in this position of
saying wait a second the specific link
that these politicians are talking about
between the video games and the mass
shootings that one we've got a fight but
there are lots of other things I wish we
could be talking more about and I can't
agree with you more David so I think the
most dangerous thing about doing this is
that it deflects from the variables that
I think are actually linked to mass
shootings right so so by creating a
political discussion about violence and
video games you're turning away from
factors that I think actually contribute
and even if you do something about
violence in video games let's say you
reduce like violent exposure to video
games the data suggests that there are
far more important variables that
actually correlate with school shootings
which are doing nothing about like what
what would be those variables so to be
blunt access to guns so you the number
of people who play video games and
access to violent video games is
basically the same all over the world
and you can look at societies like the
UK and Australia as being so CR
economically and culturally like close
to the United States and they have like
400 so we have 450 times as many
shooting related deaths as the UK even
though our our exposure to video games
is about the same so what's that its
population adjusted because we have
drastically different populations as
well it's so so in the United States
it's four point four three deaths per
hundred thousand people got it in the UK
I think it's 0.6 OH deaths per hundred
thousand people so it's absolutely
population adjusted and so why do we
have like 400 times more like deaths
related to guns if
the UK and the US we're playing the same
amount of video games it has to be
something else and there are studies
that show that for example in Australia
after the Christchurch shooting they
implemented very strong gun control laws
yeah and the amount of shootings went
way down yeah well I mean I think that
there may be a relatively small sample
size anyway to compare to compare to in
a country with a far smaller population
but I think that I look forward to
seeing the full data on that I think
you're starting to get to I mean yeah
for me access to guns is absolutely a
part of this but there's something else
which is actually a much more cultural
thing which I want to talk to you about
churches I think that in the United
States there is much more of a culture
either as a sort of a definitive thing
or as a de facto thing of seeing
firearms as a way to solve different
types of problems that is different than
in other countries the idea that if
there is a political problem you might
be able to solve it with a firearm if
there is an an interpersonal or a
personal mental health issue or
grievance of some kind that the firearm
is seen as a tool in a way that does not
seem to be the case in many other
countries I think that's a really astute
observation and I think that so the
where I kind of go from that is where do
people get that idea right so you're
saying that people are fundamentally
viewing firearms is solutions to
problems and I think what's more
dangerous than video games far more
dangerous is actually these sort of
echo-chamber toxic communities on the
internet which like the more I've done
stuff with healthy gamer the more I sort
of get people who are looking for help
and and the more I sort of sort of see
this side of the internet and you can
look at some of these communities like
8chan and you know reddit recently has
been banning certain subreddits and
things like that and they're basically
communities where some kind of toxic
mentality or violence as a solution gets
propagated and these communities are so
sort of incestuous that you kind of
don't get any sort of outside
perspective and so people start to they
believe something and then everything
that they read and every person
they talk to as a member of this
community reinforces that belief and
then someone from this community goes
and gets their 15 minutes of fame by
shooting up you know Walmart or school
and then they're actually like lauded
within these communities they're there
they're viewed as like heroes and so I
think that kind of that kind of like
psychological indoctrination which is
going on through through some of these
toxic internet communities is like
really dangerous so could there be sort
of like a third factor correlation where
you have maybe the shootings that there
may be a correlation with the the sort
of antisocial self-perpetuating echo
chambers of hate that exists online and
it just so happens that many of the
people in those communities happen to
also be playing video games because of
their sort of societal or social
situation but that is not a causal
connection is that a possibility
absolutely so so what you're talking
about is essentially something called a
confounding variable which is something
that's related to the the root and the
outcome but is actually like somewhat
separate so I think that the the gaming
community in some of these toxic
internet communities have a heavy amount
of overlap there's also a heavy amount
of overlap with mental health that's
tends to be pretty undiagnosed and so I
think that you know people who spend a
lot of time sort of living on the
Internet also play video games because
that's a major form of their recreation
it's a major form of their community and
video games can build community both
like positive community and negative
community I've worked with people who
you know have felt like the community
they've gained through the internet is
really important to them so I think it's
absolutely possible that it's kind of a
third variable and related to each of
those but is not causal you you talked
about undiagnosed mental health stuff so
without diagnosing any particular people
or particular shooters I let's dig in a
little bit to the mental health thing
because that's also a common talking
point which is the problem of gun
violence is mental health and not access
to guns one thing is which we don't have
to get into that a lot of the same
people claiming that aren't doing
anything to increase access to mental
health treatment and that's just an
obvious hypocrisy which we don't have to
sort of drill it drill down on right now
but
we want to think about mental health
what are the conditions that we're
talking about that may in in this world
where we take the mental health issue
more seriously preclude someone from
legal access to a firearm is there some
set list that anyone has proposed I've
not seen one and that raises a whole
host of new questions as well I mean
does anxiety mean if we take mental
health seriously if you die next with
diagnosed with anxiety you don't get a
gun I mean that's a whole other
Pandora's box well yeah so David I think
there's a subtle problem in the way that
you're framing your question and you're
presuming that because you're accepting
the premise that mental health leads to
gun violence right well that I'm saying
even if we could establish that then
what do we do so I'm not necessarily
accepting it I'm saying what if what if
it were true then how would we even deal
with that yeah so I think that that
becomes problematic because when we talk
about mental illness there are two kinds
of mental illness like you can lump
mental illness into two big categories
yes
one is personality disorders so these
are not things that happen to you these
are part of who you are so when we think
of someone like a sociopath or a
psychopath that's not a condition that
someone sort of randomly gets afflicted
with you can be like for example a
postpartum mother and experienced
depression for the first time in your
life right so some mental health issues
or things that sort of happen to you you
can develop anxiety you can develop
depression in some parts of what we
consider mental health or mental
illnesses are actually like baked into
your personality structure so when I
think about people the profile of a
school shooter these are people that
have something more personality oriented
and don't necessarily I don't think that
the social anxiety that they have which
many of them experience is causative
it's a factor but I think the social
anxiety leads to isolation which then
sort of creates this this interesting
like perfect storm of social isolation
toxic internet communities glorification
of gun violence and then you sort of end
up with a school shooter so I don't
think there's a particular diagnosis but
if it's anything it's probably something
more
in the realm of personality disorder as
opposed to something like depression or
anxiety yeah yesterday I was talking to
former neo-nazi Frank mink who in the
90s got out of that movement and when I
said what was it that could have
prevented you from getting in in the
first place because life circumstances
seemed to be very similar for a lot of
the people that get sucked into those
movements and eventually commit
real-world violence he said that empathy
from others when he was growing up was
what he identified and what's
interesting about that is that doesn't
seem to be linked so much to the inbuilt
personality disorders that you're
talking about and seems more
circumstantial absolutely so David I
think this is exactly what how healthy
gamer has evolved because what I realize
is it's not like a mental illness that's
causing this there are other factors
it's isolation it's a lack of empathy
it's feeling powerless it's it's sort of
viewing the world in a very like tinted
way and so I think a big problem when
we're kind of talking about gaming and
gamers is that a lot of people are
talking about gamers you have you have
people like us like I'm an expert and
you know like radio shows we're talking
about gamers politicians are talking
about gamers researchers are talking
about gamers and I think what what
you're what Frank minx story illustrates
is that it's talking to the person
that's actually the most important right
it's forming an empathic connection with
an individual human being that causes
someone to change their lives and and
it's I completely agree with that 100%
and that sort of the ethos around
healthy gamer which is like we need to
start talking to people who are
struggling and help that like help them
it's not about gun control
it's not about increased access to
mental health resources it's on a very
fundamental level if you think about
what worked for Frank mink it's an
individual human reaching out to him and
like making an empathic connection and
that's really what we're trying to do
and I think that's really what the
overall answer is it's not restricting
access based on a diagnosis it's it's
connecting to individual human beings
who feel isolated and helping them feel
connected and here for a difficult thing
to do
in a large scale for sure we've been
speaking with psychiatrist Alok Kenosha
who's also co-founder of healthy gamer
so great to have you back on although
not under the best circumstances yeah
thank you very much David it was awesome
being on the show and thank you